zur meldung hat die frau bundesminister
am dienstag reist
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
nach salzburg um den angekündigten
verbesserungen bei der miliz taten
folgen zu lassen
dabei erinnert sie an den
alternativlosen einsatz der miliz in der
kroner krise aber eines ist auch klar
auch die besten soldatinnen und soldaten
können keine einsätze durchführen wenn
das notwendige fahrzeug dafür fehlt und
die ersten 35 von insgesamt 200 werden
am dienstag übergeben
das ist immer beliebter lastkraftwagen
mit dem mit seinen sechs verschiedenen
aufbau möglichkeiten alles notwendige
transportiert werden kann
für den miliz beauftragten des
bundesheeres generalmajor erwin haben es
jeder ist der tag der übergabe ein
freudentag für die miliz ein sehr
symbolträchtigen tag denn und sehr
eindrucksvoll auf das die miet- und
damit auch das österreichische
bundesheer in umsetzung des
regierungsprogramms mit konkreten karten
und maßnahmen gestärkt wird die übergabe
der 35 neuen lkw an die jäger partie
ohne salzburg oberösterreich und tirol
ist aber erst der anfang das miliz paket
das bringt viele verbesserungen in den
bereichen bewaffnen ausrüstung und
mobilität ja und im rahmen dieses
paketes bekommt die truppe insgesamt 300
die restlichen 165 fahrzeuge sollen bis
ende des jahres an das österreichische
bundesheer ausgeliefert werden